في هذه الاثناء تظاهر عشرات من ذوي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في غزه قباله
المدخل الرئيسي لمقر وزاره الدفاع في تل
ابيب وذلك بالتزامن مع انعقاد جلسه لمجلس
الحرب وطالب المتظاهرون بابرام صفقه تبادل
على الفور واعاده الاسرى المحتجزين وهم
على قيد الحياه وقبل فوات الاوان ورفع
المئات لافتات تطالب رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو ببذل ما في وسعه لارجاع الرهائن
الىى ذويهم في طالب مشاركون في المظاهره
باستقاله
نتنياهو تنضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسله
الجزيره نجوان سمري نجوان ما الذي يحدث
فعليا وحقيقه الخلافات في اروقه السياسه
الاسرائيليه يعني خلافات كثيره جلال لكن
حاليا اسرائيل ما زالت في حاله ترقب للرد
من جانب حركه حماس لذلك اعلن هذا اليوم عن
امتناع نتنياهو لعقد اجتماع اخر للمجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه
كي لا يحصل مجددا ان تخرج عنه تسريبات
تعلن او يعلن من خلالها هذه من خلال هذه
التسريبات الموقف الاسرائيلي الرسمي من
هذه الصفقه لان اخفاء الموقف
الاسرائيلي وما يدور في هذه في هذه
الاجتماعات سواء كان مجلس الحرب ولكن
تحديدا المجلس الوزاري المصغر الذي تكرر
في الايام الاخيره ان يتم تسريب ما يدور
فيه هي جزء من ال المفاوضات واستراتيجيه
المفاوضات ايضا التي يجريها رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو هذا اليوم راينا مدى
الخلاف بشان صفقه التبادل اربعه وزراء
خلال جلسه الحكومه الاسبوعيه من حزب
الليكود وليس فقط من احزاب الصهيونيه
الدينيه مثل تسلس موتش وتمار بن كفير
هاجموا هذه الصفقه وقالوا بان اسرائيل لا
ينبغي ان توافق على اطار المقترح الذي
تم في باريس وكذلك قالوا بان الهدنه
الطويله ستضر
ب العمليات العسكريه وما وصفوه ايضا
بالانجازات التي حققها الجيش وطالب و ان
يتم من الان وصاعدا بحث كل ما يتعلق بملف
اعاده الاسرى وصفقه التبادل على الهيئه
العامه للحكومه وليس فقط في مجلس ال الحرب
وعدم وضعهم تحت الامر الواقع لكن قبل قليل
افادت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان هذا
الهجوم كان مدفوع
من ديوان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
ضمن استراتيجيه يتبعها نتنياهو في هذا هذه
المفاوضات للقول بالاساس للجانب الامريكي
للاداره الامريكيه بانه ليس الوحيد الذي
يرفض هذا المنحى للصفقه وانما تقع عليه
ضغوطات من وزراء في حكومته وليس فقط من
الوزراء في اقصى اليمين وانما حتى وزراء
من حزب الليكود يعرضون هذه الصفقه ايضا في
رسائل للجانب الفلسطيني
ولحركة
على هذا
المنحى المطروح من جهه اخرى ايضا سرب هذا
اليوم عن نتنياهو قوله ان مفتاح التبادل
الاسرى الذي عملت به اسرائيل في الدفعه
الاولى او في الصفقه الاولى التي
ابرمت سابقا بين الجانبين هو ما سيسري
ايضا في هذه الصفقه في اشاره الى ان عدد
الاسرى التي تطالب فيهم حركه حماس الاسرى
الفلسطينيين مقابل الاسرى الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في غزه غير مقبول اسرائيليا
والحديث يدور عن 150 اسيرا مقابل كل مجنده
وعندما يتحدث اسرائيل عن مفتاح الصفقه
السابقه فهذا يعني ثلاثه اسرى مقابل كل
اسير اسرائيلي جلال شكرا لك نجوان في تل
ابيب